[Music]
hey everybody mr. wonderful here with
another episode of ask mr. wonderful you
know I gotta be honest with you it's my
favorite show I love it because it's
your questions that make it happen and
today we're gonna take a little drive
down a tech alley with an amazing guy
who's gonna be really useful and
answering some of these questions so
let's not waste any time we're gonna
jump right into it everybody meet sam
Schieffer hello that's it that's all you
got
I'm waiting for you Kevin you're driving
the bus here I got it I want to know Sam
where you came from everybody does what
makes you special in the tech world
how'd you get these followers what's the
story on your journey into YouTube and
why do you love tech so much those are
multiple questions fast on your feet
when you're working with me all right
give me give me like two minutes
I'm from New Jersey born and raised I
come from a relatively big family I've
got an older brother and two younger
brothers so growing up I we had video
games in the house computers
I remember burning CDs it's using
Napster early on Kazaa LimeWire all of
those things using Napster illegally
shame on you that's right and just being
really on the Internet in the sort of
early in late 90s and I remember getting
on Twitter relatively early and I
somehow landed a job at a website called
Engadget when I was 19 years old
a truckers and I worked at Engadget for
two years remotely and then all the
editors left and gadgets to start a new
website called The Verge in 2011 and I
was a team of one running social media
for The Verge it's very early on in the
social media game yeah yeah yeah it's
been interesting to watch the last
decade of kind of there was I remember
there was a time where people thought
Twitter was not gonna last and now
Twitter is one of the most important
platforms like of our life and then from
the verge I started dabbling in video a
little bit I've always my dad actually
used to have camcorders around the house
all the time so I've been exposed to
cameras basically my whole life and then
really when I was at the verge I
kind of just volunteered myself we did a
daily tech news show called 90 seconds
on the verge and everyday I would
volunteer to film the show cuz I you
know I love tech news and you were
shooting on what old videotape hey yeah
right we were shooting on I think Canon
c100 I personally was never really
behind the cameras always in front of
the camera which was nice and then from
the verge I worked at Mashable I was
there from 2017 no I was there from 2015
to 2017
I ran our snapchat discover channel so
we had a tech focus snapchat it was like
a snapchat only show and that was kind
of crazy because we'd make a dozen
pieces of content every day Kevin and
then they would disappear after 24 hours
7 days a week for a long time but but
that was the format that not only were
you gonna do it that way I guess but you
somehow found a way to stay engaged with
people that want to hear what you've got
definitely and I it's interesting I I
don't really consider myself like huge
like I have friends with literally
millions of followers on Instagram and
Twitter and tens of millions on YouTube
and I think that people that follow me
are sort of in it for the long journey
where some of my audience knows me from
when I was literally 21 22 years old
working at Engadget in The Verge some
people only know me from YouTube but
when you consider yourself though a
social media entrepreneur because you're
trying to use these platforms in a way
that you can monetize them and you can
eat yeah yeah and you know in some ways
if you go back just 20 years everybody
want to be a rock star and everybody
wants to be a youtuber and you think
about the same desire not everybody
makes it what do you think
differentiates so let's call it let's
call the hurdle it's not easy to get
50,000 subs subs or subscribers it's not
easy to get 100,000 it's nearly
impossible to get a million and that's
what it takes over time to live off
YouTube and have a successful
entrepreneurial business that's right
what differentiates the winners and the
losers let's just take one platform
let's just go YouTube for a minute here
because we're on this platform right now
who did like how is it determined who
who gets the light to shine on them in
the rest day in the darkness
I think there's a couple of facets that
go into this consistency is really
really important I think does that mean
when you say consistency that means if
they're time to release every week does
it mean the quality every week yes I
think it's it's a combination of just
upload a damn video to YouTube and
continue to upload videos to YouTube
where you know they're huge time
commitment for anybody that wants to go
down there yes and and I think that part
of it mentally you need to go into it
with you know like obviously if you're
trying to make a business out of it
that's a great angle but you need to
find enjoyment out of it if it starts to
feel like a burden on you and you think
that's the dream of YouTube or you can
find a passion a topic matter you love
like tech for you and all of a sudden
get a following just like a band has a
following in the old days you have to
sell album to your band you know fans
and here you are building up a franchise
of people that want to care about give a
damn what you think number to trust what
you say and see consistently get content
from you and a quality they're used to
that sounds like the magic to make it
work I so I have a very specific good
anecdote for you so I publish not as
often as I should and what is that
what's the frequency at this point Kevin
I would say it's like I try to hit once
a week but realistically it's like twice
a month but I'm I've very much like up
to the quality where if you go back for
my older videos audio is not as good the
just the I used to only shoot in 1080
now I only shoot in 4k and it really
makes a difference but the the
consistency aspect I remember early 2019
I was just going super hard on YouTube
just like getting really consistent I
had a it's nice to have like when you
have like two in the hopper three in the
hopper where you're like ahead of
schedule where you have two videos ready
to go with a bow on them and you can
publish them whenever you want that's a
dream if you can that is and and I I
basically have I work with one of my
younger brothers who's also my roommate
he quit his job in banking to help me
make youtube videos and is he eating
protein he is he definitely makes
protein shakes on some well but no we've
we had a really good 2019 there was one
video
the whole point I'm making Kevin it's
it's usually just takes one single video
that could really put you on the map so
I made a video called Instagram story
hacks five things you probably didn't
know you can do and Instagram is just so
hot where there's so many people just
searching on YouTube because YouTube is
the second largest search engine in the
world second to Google enough people are
searching Instagram story tricks
Instagram story hacks so I hit it good
with SEO in the title and the tags and
it got like 30 or 40 thousand views in
like two or three days so I was like
alright cool I had like I don't know a
hundred eighty thousand subscribers in
one week it just shot up in the YouTube
algorithm that video is five and a half
million views and I've gained 49
thousand subscribers from a single video
so there is a music analogy to that it
takes one big hit to get your band on
the map and then people want to listen
to what else you've got it's great
analogy to YouTube let's jump into some
questions because I've got a whole ton
of questions there tech origins your
beginning you're gonna be the right guy
to co-author these answers with me which
is what I love to do in collaborations
we have a lot of fun so let's listen to
what these people are asking and think
about how we can help them advance their
cause because everybody asks these
questions for a reason they're trying to
do something better faster a business
and entrepreneur decide if they want to
actually get into something in terms of
a new idea in tech and everything in
tech has been done before it seems until
the next big idea comes along so let's
start with this this is from Charlie
Charlie what do you got for us
hey mr. wonderful we're rapidly entering
the age of autonomous cars do you think
car ownership will continue to be a
priority for most or do you see people
preferring to use them as needed via a
subscription service hmm you know that's
a great question that has a great
question there's a lot he's insinuating
a lot what he's basically saying is if
everybody's willing to jump in an
autopilot a cart on this car why should
you own it so let's start with you what
do you think about this question because
it has a lot of implications on how you
would invest in car companies a la Tesla
which is a hot stock right now what do
you think what's the answer to charli's
question there's a lot to unpack here
I am first of all I'm extremely bullish
on Tesla Elon has now completed part one
of his master plan I think that I am
personally a little bit in my own bubble
because I've lived in Manhattan for
about seven years now and I haven't you
know really owned those are the
Manhattan police sirens I hear that
they're constantly there's noise here so
like my use for car I've rode here on an
electric longboard my use for a car is
effectively zero right now like I
wouldn't I did pre-order cyber truck
because I don't know where I'm gonna be
when I think ships in two or three years
but I think that in terms of autonomous
vehicles we are definitely and I hope
going toward a future where cars drive
themselves I make this analogy with sort
of naysayers that are like the cars can
be hacked and this and that and I say
when you pick up your phone to call your
mom or your cousin or your boss and you
send a text message or an email you're
not worried about someone intercepting
that call you're not worried about
something getting hacked yes there is a
chance that something catastrophic could
happen but I think traffic deaths in the
US alone in 2017 or 2018 was like
upwards of 35,000 you think those are
the way down once cars are watching
themselves yes I think so
I have used driving has a promise of
making me maybe making it safer I agree
with that do you use you own and operate
a an electric vehicle I do and I'll tell
you my answer this question comes from
experience yes in a rather different way
my son's electrical engineer in his
third year decides to take an internship
at Tesla we're sitting at the kitchen
table he gets invited he accepts he's
really interested because he was on the
car team at his college and a lot of
people don't know this every cohort
engineering electrical engineers race f1
formula cars they built from scratch
against each other
MIT generally would beat everybody but
in this particular Nebraska race Trevor
who was the captain of the team beat MIT
now of course at all these races the
tests like guys and all in the BMW guys
and the Audi guys and the Ford guys are
running around meeting these teams so
his team did very well he's a
not sort of a battery management side he
got an internship but here's the story
we're sitting at the kitchen table I'm
looking over at my screen because I
managed you know I'm in the financial
services industry with ETFs and I'm
looking over and Tesla's down 13%
because they missed a quarter or an
analyst said too short the stock or
whatever I said to Trevor this company
looks like a dog this thing is down so
much he said dad nobody understands this
company this is not a car company it's a
data company it has the highest
resolution of miles driven on earth
every time a Tesla drives it reports
back to HQ and makes the resolution of
that road even clearer for future
autonomous driving and I said what does
that mean Trevor should I not think if
this is a car company said no think
about it as a data company with
extremely high-resolution data and you
should own some so I bought some stock
you know this is the highest return on
any stock I own because that was the low
that day just by happen chance and I'm
up like I don't know 90% and it's the
car company barely makes any money this
is why I always listen to people that
know more about something than I do
and Trevor clearly understood that he
had a different vision for what Tesla
was he loved working there but to me
that is the future and boy am I glad I
own that stock and to Elon who I would
saw recently out in LA I thanked him
I said listen Elon all I know about you
is you've made me money
hahahahaha and that's a good guy it is
great but let's move on I think you said
it we're both pretty positive on that
thank you for your question Charley
I love the randomness of these clothes I
just never know that gets pretty broad
these days I'd say Michel is asked
asking this question
I'm so wonderful I have a question for
you that if you had $30,000 in the bank
stored up from my savings that you have
as a students working would you invest
at all or would you do the 10% everyone
the best only 10% of it and only invest
10% for income out of time should I save
it for my graduate school or invest it
Sam tough question 30,000 per student
he's not even in debt but he's going to
go into debt if he goes second
post-secondary college right that is a
really tough question to answer
ouu take it first I wanna hear us is
it's very simple for me I hate debt
Michelle I hate that I can't stand debt
if you have $30,000 invested in yourself
in college but don't go into debt while
you're in college do what I did get a
job at night I was slinging beer and I
worked as a chef just so I never got
into debt in college I hate that but I
would not invest it until you're
finished your journey and I look at it
this way you should make a decision if
you're gonna take thirty thousand
dollars that are in the bank right now
you better invest in a degree that makes
sense in terms of monetizing it and I've
said this many times I get criticized
for it all the time the top three for me
engineering number one engineering
number two and engineering number three
and if you want a fourth choice go with
engineering because if you have the
aptitude to do that the chances you
won't be employed are practically zero
and you'll make lots of money everything
else I don't know it's hard to say what
do you think Sam this might sound a
little crazy but I don't $30,000 is not
that much in the grand scheme of things
like if if you if you don't have it yes
but but if if this person's thinking in
you know sort of ten years from now
hopefully they're gonna have much more
than thirty thousand not a it should
make seven percent a year if it's
invested in the market the question is
should you go in debt instead of using
that to get to invest in your own
education and here's another further
question if you don't really believe in
your education that you would invest in
it what the hell are you doing that's
right that's right I think I think
Michelle should take it upon himself to
you know ask himself what does he really
want if he's if he's okay with investing
the thirty thousand into himself
you said to pursue the education then
hopefully he'll be able to make a ton
more money that he can recoup that debt
if need be are you okay with let's say
you had three kids and they all want to
do history and the liberal arts and
pursue music and you're still paying for
all of their lives I mean this is a very
touchy question yeah people feel I'm not
against the arts at all but you have to
have a plan that you can actually
separate from your parents by the time
you're 18 and make it on your own what's
the strategy you know what's funny is
this is just speaking solely from my
perspective you found a way I really
didn't have a plan frankly I your father
still writing you a check every week no
no no no my parent I haven't really
taken money for my they pay for my phone
bill and that's literally it I've been
paying rent for yeah probably seven
years now you're in financially oh yes
super financially independent your mind
every week you're thinking about how do
I live my life in a way that I can
afford it well how can I live my my life
in a way this this is gonna sound a
little bit also a little bit crazy but
we're talking here why not I think money
is is super fascinating especially in
this like future that we live in because
there's everyone in the universe is
bound by money but you really don't need
like a hundred million dollars to like
find you know inner peace with yourself
like I have a moderately good-sized
apartment in the East Village in
Manhattan I'm able to like buy my meals
going out I'm not a Multi gazillionaire
but I'm also not like you know
scavenging for for pennies and nickels
here I've worked really hard for the
past ten years but I think it's
important to like take a look at what
you want like how are you able to wake
up every morning and say like I'm gonna
go work and for me it's for myself and
be able to save money and just like not
go crazy about like where's my next
dollar because you're not under stress
that many people if they don't know
where next month's of rent is that's
right that puts tremendous stress on you
physically always being in uncertainty
and not knowing or being in such so much
debt that you might face personal
bankruptcy which changes your life
forever it's right and you know hurts
you in many
in the future I think this issue is an
interesting one because you sound like
you're a happy guy you found a a medium
where you're you know you're not
starving and you're happy what you've
built for yourself and you're able to
pay for yourself that's right and so I
think that's what everybody strives for
and so what in regard to you know
Michele's $30,000 he's making a decision
about launching himself to get to where
you are eventually yeah and he may start
with that in the bank or he may decide
to invest it in college or you know in
in master's degree or something like
that but I always tell people all the
time when you're looking at $30,000 you
saved hard and you're gonna invest in
education you better make it something
you can get back that's right and so
whatever makes you happy and actually
something that you're good at maybe
you'll get them employed in it because
not everybody's gonna be an entrepreneur
but I love that question and I just want
to add one more thing also like with
patients I mean this person if they're
still undergrad you know 19 20 21 years
old that $30,000 if they go pursue you
know get a master's degree in
engineering or something they're they're
looking at a hundred thousand dollar
salary in their first year possibly
master's degree in engineering it costs
you 60 to 80 grand including that's
right it ain't so so patience right you
take hit pause on your life and and then
you know press play when you're 25 26
after you've been working for four or
five makes the assumption you've decided
this career path will get me a job which
is something you got to think about if
you're gonna part with $30,000 that's
all I say to people think about it I
mean just think about it I get the high
school journey but when you go in and
you start paying for college that's an
investment in yourself make it worth it
like going to college and just blowing
your brains up partying is a real waste
of dough if there's no outcome in the
other end which is the mistake I made
when I went to college my dad said
you're gonna starve to death you better
go back and get a master's in business
cuz you are going to just have no income
and that's what you did yeah I was a
shuffleboard expert you know and I went
did arts and it's a long step I made my
money hustling shuffleboard against
engineers who all got jobs and I was
still at that's exactly what happened
here's one from Luke what's the one
thing that someone should
if they want to improve their appearance
but don't have unlimited funds
interesting what's the one luke is
asking what's the one thing someone
should invest in to improve their
appearance so he's making an assumption
about how important appearance is but
they don't have a lot of money what do
you think that is should we unpack this
here for a second it's an interesting
question is appearance a haircut is it
is is it your you know your apparel is
it
I think intrinsic and Luke's question is
the idea that somehow the your
appearance your image your image your
brand your Karma
what other people think about you when
they first see you which happens every
day people see you for the first time
all over that's scary it's true though
and so I think people should consider
their brand their image the way they
look and they can decide to look
different ways for different groups but
I'll give you an example when I go to
meet with money when I'm in financial
services talking about oh she airs ETS
eyewear a crisp suit a white shirt a tie
shiny shoes because that's what they
expect to see when I'm sitting here with
you here right now having a great time
I'm selling my own merch by the way a
time to promote this when I'm here
pitching my own merch cold hard merch
calm very exclusive shirt I just love
this piece by the way I think we have a
limited number but you'll learn more
about it later but you know I'm always
selling what can you say but my point is
I want to feel comfortable talking with
you and you're not wearing a suit so why
should I
and we understand each other on this
thing so at the end of the day what's
your answer to Luke
what can you do you know have a lot of
dough but you want to change your image
what's the plan tough question is really
tough question I would say authenticity
like be comfortable with yourself you
know you can look good in anything you
could also look bad in anything if you
get a weird haircut and you don't feel
comfortable in it it's going to sort of
like seep through and people gonna be
able to sense that you're uncomfortable
and you literally your own skin I also
think good sleep is vastly underrated
there's just like this you know I like I
like that where's this notion of work
work work I mean like you work jobs
through college you know staying up all
night like it's
and it makes money but like quality
sleep is vastly underrated so Luke if
you're not getting a good night's sleep
I think you should personally invest in
in a really good night's sleep and it'll
just make you sort of feel better
overall and then just be comfortable in
your own skin I'm gonna give you a
little a little data that I learned a
couple of weeks ago I got hired to be a
keynote speaker to a group of HR
executives human resources executive
works for large corporations and when we
were doing that the breakout after the
keynote maybe I had 15 of them in a room
no press no just open dialogue and I
asked them a question because in these
giant companies that they write policy
books about appearance about apparel
about protocol in HR but I asked them
because I had a discussion with my
daughter earlier that day about tattoos
and inking yourself you know because
everybody's doing it these days so I
said to them I'd like to get an answer
I'm not recording anything I'm not
taping anything when when a candidate
comes in for a job fantastic resume and
they have ink on their face they've got
a tattoo on their face of their neck or
it's exposed in a way on their head does
that in any way change your perception
of them for the for the job
remember no nobody's recording there was
a really long uncomfortable silence but
to a tee every one of them said yeah
that freaks me out
I worry about how the messaging is to
our customers to other employees if
they're uncomfortable there's a red
lightning bolt across their forehead or
imagery up the side of their neck and so
I'm telling people and I'm not endorsing
either way but if you're gonna ink
yourself in your face and you're going
into and you want to pursue a path with
a large company and by the way a lot of
these were tech HR guys with companies
that you know that you want to get a job
at they're not cool with it what do you
think about that face tattoos exists in
this really sort of like singular
category
like it gives off like I don't know III
also like on the one hand to give off a
rebel without a cause vibe there's a yes
I don't give a [ __ ] what you think vibe
yes
I mean to permanently inks look nothing
against people that tattoo themselves on
their neck on their hands on their face
but it's just like it sends a message
you know it sends this is it a good
message for your career this is the
question we're trying to answer here if
they're qualified it shouldn't matter it
shouldn't matter do you think it does I
am NOT a hiring manager Kevin but I
think if I were to ever do risk it
because there's always two candidates
there's always two resumes there's
always one in our case we're discussing
here I would I would because you could
always fire them if they're not
performing interesting answers so you
support that rebel nature because maybe
what matters is their ability to execute
maybe they're a brilliant mind but I I
think my answer is I think they're
selected against in a way that's not
fair but it happens anyways so I just
want the viewership to understand
there's a risk to this it's not free and
if you do it you're taking at least for
some people you're telling them
something they don't want to hear that's
what I'm saying
I have no tattoos if I were either do I
but I have nothing against them I have
no problem with it we have lots of and
my companies everybody's got tattoos I
don't give a [ __ ] but I'm trying to give
advice to people they're trying to
advance their careers in some amazing
companies that I know they want to work
at and these HR guys were clear they
were clear so Luke no face tats face
tests that's the first thing
look that's good let's move on alright
Michel what do you got for us Michelle
hi mr. wonderful what do you think of
the hype around 5g do you think it'll
revolutionize our homes jobs and the way
we travel or do you think it's largely
just marketing hype Sam honey sweetie
poopsie baby 5g that's right up your
alley what are you thinking on 5g
marketing hype or real benefit both
story time when I was a truckers I
remember the iPhone 5 came out Rutgers
universities in New Brunswick New Jersey
and it was
first cities to light up 4G LTE LTE is
long-term evolution it kind of got
bundled like 4G was the fourth
generation of wireless tech for
smartphones and then like branding sort
of blended like 4G LTE it's the same
thing anybody even understand what the
hell that means no no it just means
about how fast can you scroll through
Instagram without waiting for the video
to buffer basically for halt that that's
if you understand what that is sure sure
it's it's how fast are you basically
pulling data from towers which are
getting data from satellites it's when I
was at Rutgers and I remember vividly I
would do speed tests on my iPhone 5 or
5s whichever one had LTE first I think
it was the five I was getting like 50 or
60 down which is pretty good speeds even
by today's standards this is this is
literally 2009 2010 there's a lot less
pressure on the network at that time
that's exactly what I was going to get
at there was no one else that had an
iPhone with LTE every guy and their dog
is putting pressure in the network that
is right so in the beginning days LTE
was fantastic I remember just being
obsessed with doing speed test I was
getting sometimes over a hundred down
like in a moving car and I was like this
is awesome this is like faster than my
Wi-Fi at home this is ten years ago now
the networks are so congested that no
matter where like we are in New York
City one of the most densely populated
cities in the world no matter what
network you have it is not great the
promise of LTE and 4G didn't really I in
my opinion pan out to be some super
extraordinary thing like it there are
times where my data is great where I can
you know brow is tick-tock and watch
YouTube videos about buffer and then
there are also times where my data is
like yep this is this is cellular
service in 2020 and it's it's not great
I think we are at a time right now where
Michelle if you go spend the money on a
5g phone and you go on Verizon or you go
on t-mobile there's like the oneplus 70
Pro has a 5g version I think one but how
far what what's the distribution of 5g
right now and even major major
let's talk Chicago New York's Miami LA
maybe Houston maybe Dallas a little bit
of technicality here there's a few
different thing it's it's basically
[ __ ] it's all marketing right now
for now yes for now of course companies
are gonna race to say we have the first
5g Network
Verizon is doing the millimeter wave 5g
so five G in order to roll out the
infrastructure there needs to be
physical boxes these literally gray
boxes no matter who you are you can be
Verizon be ATT you can be anybody else
you still need the 5g boxes there are
these and that there are a density of
the vicinity of those boxes
alright I'll answer your question
without spewing too much text yeah don't
make it so tough okay shame on you
right now 5g is I would say 75%
marketing and 25% practical where you
need to be in a 5g city in order to take
close to the transponder yes
marques Brownlee who was a guest on your
show a couple of weeks ago has two great
videos on his channel about 5g if you're
interested in 5g go watch his videos he
explains it you need to have a direct
line of sight you need to be in a city
where these boxes are I would say
Michelle this is January of 2020 let's
talk again and I've literally 2020 to
let Apple put out a fight I think Apple
might do a 5g phone this year but the
networks aren't ready yet I have a
different take of this from a practical
reason I travel sometimes in a week to
seven cities the internet is [ __ ]
everywhere really is and I carry two
phones with me would you pass that that
blue one on the table there the reason I
carry two phones these are live two
phones multiple accounts is winter four
networks seven different networks one is
81 is Verizon because in any city one of
them doesn't work I know they like to
say oh they're the best no they're not
they don't work you have to if you're on
the East Coast you want Verizon if you
in the West Coast 180 in the hills of
Hollywood
you've got garbage nothing works in the
hills of Hollywood the point is between
the two of them they have a lot of work
to do and I love both these companies I
don't want to bash them because I know
how hard it is but the internet in
America should
like electricity when you turn it on it
should work and you should never be you
know crapped out in it the way I am all
over the place
I think and my hope is that 5g in the
next five years will make it ubiquitous
like electricity so the devices and
people can work together and have a
consistency that we don't have now and
I'm saying this on the record the
internet sucks mobile Internet it's [ __ ]
it's absolute [ __ ] I expect so much more
so for both Verizon AT&T and all the
other players in here you guys have a
lot of work to do because mr. wonderful
is very unhappy and I'm not the only one
you know exactly what I'm talking about
let's take another question here I love
that question that was great all right
John hit us hey mr. wonderful John from
Kentucky I just wanted to know your
opinion on moonlighting a business if
you have a full-time job and a family
full of hungry mouths to feed and say
you're in my position and you're the
sole breadwinner of your family wants to
know your thoughts on any extra profit
from your moonlight business how should
you use that what would you do if you
were in my shoes and you just started a
moonlit business thank you for your time
you have a good day very interesting
question he's basically at a point in
his life where he has to feed the kids
pay the rent
make sure the family's okay and still he
wants to be an entrepreneur what do you
think money's got to come from somewhere
you poo-pooed money earlier in the show
now you're thinking how tough it is for
this guy well I don't have a wife or
kids that could happen he generally does
it generally does if he's in that
position now he didn't say how old he is
it sounded to me like he was in his mid
30s okay yeah so he has a side hustle as
we'll call it right that he wants to
pursue as that's what he means by this
moonlit business that's what it is at
night he has no other time he's got to
work all day National Tire days he works
all day has little maybe some time with
his kids
they go to bed and then he goes to work
again that's tough it's it's it's like
always a question that I you know a lot
of people ask like how do you know when
to and I hate to say it like give up or
shift focus or something like that
because if he's if he's been pursuing
this business for you know three four
you can't it's too risky to jump at this
point okay I'm gonna give him some
advice here because you know better than
I do you know it's just sort of the
realities you have to take care your
family your family is always number one
you got to make sure they're safe and
fed and you're providing for them and
that is your role as that in this case
you sound like the patriarch of the
family by the way there's many cases
where women have taken over they're
making more than men and the way it
should be is they become the matriarch
of the family I'm cool in either way I
don't care but the point is somebody has
to take on the responsibility often it's
together family first
this side hustle if it starts to work
you should take every dollar you make
and retire your deck get rid of your
mortgage that's a perfect way to set up
for the point when you can actually jump
ship generally jumping ship in a new
business I'm gonna give you a number
it's three million in sales why is a
three million because most businesses
after tax make 10 or 11 percent some
make more but that's the average after
tax on all your costs so you're doing 3
million in sales you're kind of making
300 grand a year and you got to be paid
for the risk you're taking now maybe you
could do it a 2 million but I like 3
when your business is doing 3 on the
side hustle you jump ship you quit your
job boom you spend full time but that's
after you got yourself out of debt
nobody says all that sounds impossible
not true if you really want to make it
happen
you're gonna bust your ass like this guy
is doing working at night but if you've
got something that's real and sales
continue to grow you can jump off
somewhere I'll give you 2 million or 3
million but not with nothing in sales
because you don't know if the product
the product is proven yet I like that
question but I love entrepreneurs that
are willing to work basically 25 hours a
day the guy doesn't need sleep let's
hear from Valerie Guren Hauser hey mr.
wonderful 3d printing is here but so far
it's only been used for proof of
concepts and models do you think this
technology is ever going to be used for
mainstream manufacturing and if so what
do you think that will me
for everyday consumers let me set up
something before he answer it's been a
huge disappointment for investors it's
been on the market for over a decade HP
went nowhere with it so many companies
have you know heralded the advancement
of 3d printing the technology slow as
hell it's not user friendly to work with
it hasn't proven itself yet other than
modeling and doing prototypes what's
going on with 3d printing I think
there's a consumer Avenue and then
there's the sort of Enterprise Avenue
for 3d printing because okay make sure
take on both for me a consumer Avenue of
3d printing is like backing a 3d printer
on Kickstarter like the MakerBot was a
huge huge success on Kickstarter and
they're still producing them to this day
I think it's a cool I don't want to call
it a toy but it's like a cool gadget to
have in the house if you're growing up
with you know young kids or if you're
raising young kids having a 3d printer
in the home can you know sort of spark
their imagination to create whatever you
want that's assuming they can connect
with the CAD software to actually drive
it right yes but you gave it give the
kids some you know some benefit of the
doubt here maybe teach them a thing or
two just saying I'm cool with it but
it's very rudimentary compared to what
the potential of this technology is so I
mentioned earlier on the show I we had
video games in the house growing up and
might you know my parents kind of just
like got us computers and all this
attack I was always around tech and I
think that you know that really helped
spawn my love for technology from a very
young age and I think if a you know a
household has a 3d printer in it whether
it's like printing a little toy that
they find on Thingiverse or they you
know something breaks and they can you
you like it as a I'm not going to call
it a toy as an implementation of
creativity yes so you think it has merit
for that so yes family getting one has
some kids they explore it on their own
cool it's a cool thing how many homes do
you go to that have a 3d printer
same-same it's not to be a reason for
that it might be price it must be
complexity of use
I think it's barrier to entry seems high
right in terms of price well in terms of
how do you use it how do you you know
what's what extrusion are using how do
you where do you get the software from
there it seems like a very hard thing to
just like you can't just pick up a book
you can pick up a book and read it you
can't just pick up a 3d printer and
print you know for investors it's been a
bust I mean it never drove
hewlett-packard into the stratosphere
the way some people thought Epson
anybody oh the pretty companies it never
really took off as a mainstream you
think about a color inkjet printer
everybody has one that's right 3d
printer use cases are I would say maybe
we haven't found the proper use cases
for a3 or really it was trying to solve
a problem didn't really exist yes but
then there's also the enterprise route
which there are a couple of companies
that are there's one company a
particular icon that is 3d printing
cement homes and so so there's that
aspect of it where I need to get one of
those from my backyard there you go
so you could find use for it right is
that such a vertical and so expensive to
make one that can actually build a wall
with windows and holes for electricity
so so I read up on this recently the the
icon house apparently costs ten thousand
dollars to build and whether that's cost
the machinery or just cost of goods or
whatever it is
there's also another company that's
doing aerospace they want a 3d print
rockets I don't think that they've sent
a rocket out or space yet I will say
though there's one company called
gravity industries there's a gentleman
named Richard browning who built himself
a fully functional jet suit and they 3d
print with metal and a bunch of other
materials they 3d printed this sort of
suit and the structure it's jet engines
that I'll send you a link after this I
made a video about it it's it's
incredibly advanced technology for what
it does is what you're saying yes but it
is not a consumer lit-up product yes
definitely not and and all that
over the last decade just hasn't come -
it's not a TV it's not a computer where
every household house by so much tech
but I have never felt the desire to go
research 3d printers because I got to
have one because you have new use for
one yeah exactly
so I think bottom line is yeah I don't
think it's gonna go anywhere except for
the verticals you talked about in an
extreme case but it's advanced
technology for some industries that use
it to become more productive and that's
cool
I think it's cool it's not going to be a
big consumer product perhaps it's just
too complex to use maybe too expensive
listen it was a fantastic episode I've
asked mr. wonderful with a great guy Sam
here knows tech we had a terrific time
and you know it's funny the questions
always come in on a more personal basis
but somehow technology always creeps in
Sam thank you so much thank you Kevin
great to be here
great to have you and you know welcome
to my office in New York yeah it's a
good one take care everybody see you
next week